- Hello and welcome to Ed
Talks with Khan Academy.
I'm Kristen DiCerbo,
the Chief Learning
Officer at Khan Academy.
And today, I am looking forward
to talking to Dr. Ted Coe,
who is with NWEA, one of
our key partners here.
He is the Director of
Content, Advocacy and Design.
We're looking forward
to talking about math
and math learning today.
Before we get started, I wanna
remind you that Khan Academy
is a nonprofit organization
and relies on donations
from folks like you to help us continue
to be able to do our work.
So if you go to khanacademy.org/donate,
you'll find a place where you
can help keep us supported
and work in continuing our
work, so thank you for that.
I also want to acknowledge
our corporate supporters
who have come and helped us work
through the COVID-19
crisis, including AT&T,
General Motors, and Fastly.
If you would like to
listen to this conversation
or any of our previous conversations,
you can, wherever you get your podcasts,
find Homeroom with Sal, The Podcast
and you'll be able to
listen wherever you prefer,
at the gym, on your
walks, doing the dishes.
We hope you enjoy it.
So without further ado, let
me introduce Dr. Ted Coe.
So he has over 25 years of
experience as a teacher,
professor, department
chair, administrator,
and a nonprofit director,
basically weaving together
perspectives about mathematics education.
He has experience as a full-time
high school mathematics teacher,
community college faculty member,
a mathematics chair at
two community colleges,
and an assistant dean
at the university level.
And I will say, as
someone who is a graduate
of Arizona State University,
he is a fellow Sun Devil as well, welcome.
- Thank you, thank you, glad to be here.
- We are glad to have you.
So first of all, tell us what
your role is specifically.
What do you do at NWEA?
- This is an interesting question, right?
The answer is, the title
is Director of Content,
Advocacy and Design for mathematics.
And the interesting side to it is,
well, I get to advocate for content.
And so for many ways for me
it's like this dream world to be in,
where I get to kind of
imagine the kinds of things
that we wanna work on,
how do we wanna grow,
how do we want to move
beyond a focus on assessment
to teaching and learning and
getting into the classroom
and getting it, so it's
envisioning these kinds of things.
It's being able to work with
different state and districts
and get in there and roll up our sleeves
and get our hands dirty trying to solve
some pretty messy problems.
So that's a lot of what I get to do.
And so to me, it's great fun.
- That's fantastic, how did
you come to be in this role?
What was your path that
you took to end up here?
- It was so bizarre, it's
a crazy path, career path,
started out as a high school teacher,
things were going well, I
loved high school teaching,
highlight of the career, right?
Then I ended up getting pulled over
to one of the community colleges
and I actually walked
right in my first job
in the community college
system was as a chair
at Rio Salado College
in the Maricopa Community
College District.
So it was like this big sort of leap.
I ended up switching over
to another community college
in the district, Scotts
Dale and while I was there,
I ended up being involved
deeply in the mathematics
around the whole community college system
and kind of involved in the
articulation conversations
around the state and everything.
And somewhere along that time
the Park Consortium came along
and you might remember this,
this was in the early
years of the common core
and there were the two major consortium,
Park and Smarter Balanced.
And I was brought on to the
Park side of the conversation.
Arizona was one of the
governing states at the time.
And I was brought in
as one of the higher ed content experts.
And so I was dropped into
this space all of a sudden,
where I had been a college professor
and high school teacher and
now I was in this space,
where it's like, we want your input
on this multi-state assessment
that's on these new standards.
And so I'm like, "Well,
let's read the standards,
let's see what this is about."
And I got really involved
in it and so much, in fact
that eventually Park
split off of the group
that was running it,
which was called Achieve.
And Achieve was the ones for
the American Diploma Product,
helped lead the common core and all that,
and the next generation science standards.
And so they only hired me
to be their math director.
And so for the years prior
to coming into this space
at NWEA where I've been for two years,
I was the director of mathematics
there and got to work all
around the country with
great folks everywhere.
And really get to see how
the policies worked out
and the difficulties that
people were encountering
and trying to talk through
some of those things
and getting the chance to
speak all over the country.
It was great fun, it's been great fun
and it's been it one
surprise after the other.
And here I am today.
- Fantastic, that sounds great.
So let's talk a little bit
about teaching and leaning math.
Historically, there's been
all this discussion about,
should we teach procedural skills?
Should we teach conceptual understanding?
And these wars about which
one is more important
and where these is,
is that the right
conversation to be having?
- It's a tale as old as time,
at least as old as my
career has been, right?
But there's always this tension in there.
And so I've had to sit
back and think to myself
how would I describe teaching
and learning mathematics
after my 20 years of teaching?
And I was like, "Well,
how do I sum this up?"
And it was somehow
developed along the way,
but it was this idea that
look, part of what we do
in mathematics is we
teach these ways of doing
and we want you to be able to do those
but we also wanna make
sure that you're picking up
ways of thinking, and I'll
give you an example of that
in just a moment, that go
alongside habits of thinking.
So you have these ways of
thinking sort of at a core
that are bolstered by
these habits of thinking
that are then in turn
really sort of brought,
they come to the table in certain ways,
through the ways of doing
that allow you to go on
and do something bigger
with the mathematics.
An example I use quite frequently
is with this idea of ways of thinking.
And I can ask a room full
of adults this question
and basically I say something like,
"Hey, how many years was
it from December 7th, 1941
to December 7th, 2014?"
That's how long I've
been using this question.
Okay, so December 7th
2014 and by and large
you ask this to a room
full of even adults, right?
And people will sit there
and they start chewing on
an answer and they start,
"Oh, what can I do?
What can I do?"
And they go through some
mechanizations in their head
and they might think,
"Well, that's actually kind
of a subtraction problem
but I don't really need to
use subtraction to get it,"
because in this case, I'm just trying
to find this additive comparison
and this gap, if you will,
between the two numbers
and there are different ways to do it.
Maybe I wanna go from
1941 to 2000, cut it off,
and then go from 2000 to 2014,
or maybe I wanna take the whole thing.
So starting in 1941,
I wanna slide the whole thing
back a year and start at 1940.
Either way, all of these things are fair
but the majority of the
folks I asked that question,
they don't answer it
with the way of doing,
they don't do the 15 steps
of setting up the algorithm,
borrowing, not giving back all that thing,
putting the one, they don't do that,
they bring ways of
thinking to bear, right?
- Yeah.
- And I think maybe part of
why we get into this mess
is in the standards, we have
the learning progressions
and the learning progressions
and with the ways of doing.
And so it looks like the
way of doing is the goal,
but the way of doing
is just one more thing,
it's just one more piece, right?
Yeah, so I really like to emphasize
this idea of ways of
thinking with regards to
ways of thinking, ways of
doing, habits of thinking,
all of those things working together.
'Cause if you have just
one, the ways of doing,
all you've got is a box of puzzle pieces
when you're done with it, yeah.
- Right, so I'm gonna keep
going with the year example here
to push on this, so my
sister got married in 1997
and I have to say, somehow
never made this connection,
but she said to me one day,
"If you wanna know how
long we've been married,
you just take what current
year it is in add three,
because 1997 to 2003."
Then I was like, "Oh yeah,
why did I not think of that?"
(Kristen laughing)
So that's a way of doing
it, so then that's one way,
or is that how does that relate
then to ways of thinking?
And so are there many
different ways you can do it
and the ways of thinking around it?
- Yes, the idea is that
when I ask that question,
there are so many different
ways you could approach it.
You could approach it with a way of doing
and no harm, no foul.
You could approach it
with ways of thinking,
but if all you have is the way of doing
and you don't have those ways of thinking,
then when you get to
somewhere in real life,
it doesn't illuminate.
And a place where this
happens is you can ask
like where in real life,
ask this to an adult,
where in real life have
you ever actually used
division of fractions?
And I'll be surprised if you actually get
any valid answer back from
anybody and why is that?
Because if we reflect back to it,
when we were taught the
division of fractions,
those of us who were of
a certain age, right?
We were caught a way of doing
and it was totally disconnected
from ways of thinking
grounded in what does it
mean to divide so that-
- Yes, you were just
taught the procedure, yeah.
- Yeah and so you've got the procedure
but you have no place to hang it,
when it comes and shows up in real life.
- Right, that totally makes
sense, so if I'm a teacher
how do I start thinking about encouraging
these ways of thinking?
- See, that's the tricky part, right?
- Right?
- Yeah, and so one really
cool thing that happened
in the last couple years, Peter Liljedahl
came out with a book called
"Building Thinking Classrooms."
And I'm like, yes, yes, we're seeing
this emphasis shifting
to thinking, fantastic.
Because at the same time
my colleagues and I at NWEA
have been trying to work on this idea
of how can we get ways of thinking moving
and talked about in classrooms
in ways that are non-threatening, right?
That feel safe to both
teachers and students
because there's awkwardness
when we ask ourselves
thinking questions, all of
us have to stop and think,
and with thinking comes
vulnerability, right?
So we actually built out some things
called these formative
conversation starters.
And the role of the formative
conversation starters
is to basically help shape
how you might enter into
some of these kinds of conversations
that are designed to
focus on ways of thinking
and then to do it in such
a way that you also know
what it is you're trying to
listen for at the same time.
So we've got these bins,
these big ideas to nurture sense making
and then we've got clusters of questions
that unfold as you ask them and might lead
to moments of cognitive
dissonance or might lead to ahas
or might lead to places
where you step back and go,
"I really do need to think
more deeply about that."
So there are different options to do it.
You can put in classroom
routines, you can build tools,
like we're trying to build out.
But the idea is what can we do to do that?
All kinds of things, like
Peter's got in his book,
all kinds of options,
as well as what I'm offering here today.
- Yeah, so I like this idea
of conversation starters.
I think we're putting a
link to them in the chat
for folks that are following along.
Can you give us some examples,
what are some examples
of what these are and how do they work?
- Yeah, so, and sometimes
the idea like with fractions,
I might come out and we might
start with a question like,
well, what's a fraction?
And then, well, the
next question might be,
well, is a fraction one
number or two numbers?
And just sit back and talk about it.
Talk about what you
think on that, all right?
And then, well, what do you think of
when you think of three eighths?
Okay, what do you think of
when you see eight thirds?
'Cause if you're of three
eighths as three out of eight,
then eight thirds becomes something
that's maybe a little
tougher to think about.
Another example would be
a question that starts off
with like, well, what
does division do for us?
And so you wanna sit
back and you think about,
well, what does division do for us?
And then the next question would be
not to do a division problem,
but to ask a question like,
without computing how can you
think about a problem like
10 divided by one half
and to be able to go on to the next one.
Well, then how would you
think about negative 10
divided by one half, right?
And if your ways of thinking
are consistent and robust,
then your answers were
sort of gel together
but if you have fractures
and if they're disjoint,
then you kind of have to go back
and kind of try to figure
out, well, how do I get the,
I know that my thinking should
gel together with my answers
to all of these things,
what do I need to do?
How do I need to accommodate
the way I'm thinking
in order to make these things work?
From the teacher's perspective,
we help provide what you might
be listening for in these-
- I was just gonna ask that.
(Kristen laughing)
Yeah, what are the things
that you're looking for
from the teacher's perspective?
- Yeah, so like we know
that we want fraction
and we want students to be
able to think of a fraction
as a single number, as a point
on the number line, right?
But if I ask my students about fractions
and they're saying,
"Well, we're only thinking
of it as two numbers."
Then I'm talking about
something as the teacher
that's completely different
from what they're hearing.
And so it's this idea of
getting these meanings
out in the open so that we all know
that we're talking about the same thing,
so when I say fraction, you're
thinking the same thing.
Or when I talk about division,
you've got a notion of thinking of it
as a multiplicative comparison.
Or you've got way of
thinking about it in terms of
how many copies of run
thing are in another,
or this time's as large
as this thing, right?
Which when you have those ways of thinking
that a question like,
how can you think of
10 divided by one half,
doesn't become something
that's out of bounds at all.
It becomes something that
you can already hang onto
one of those previous
existing meanings of division,
if they're there, if you've
got those ways of thinking.
- Right, right, yeah, that makes sense.
So do these starters work
across ages and grade levels?
Are there things that we need to be,
what kinds of things can younger kids do
and what kinds of things
can older kids start to get?
- So the interesting thing
about them is the way,
if you go download, maybe
some people have already gone
to download the documents
just while we're sitting here.
But you'll see the entry point
into this is through an item,
it's through a standard, but the idea is
we've spent so many years
unpacking standards,
digging in and saying, let's
look at this one standard.
What we wanna do is say,
we're only using this as the entry point,
because what we wanna
do is we wanna find out,
what is all of the other
mathematics that has to come in
alongside it to help get through this.
We tend to look at an item
go, this is the standard.
And then we say, well,
if they get it wrong,
then we wanna go back
and go to that nearest
connecting standard.
What we're saying here is
actually maybe you wanna go
ask them about what's a fraction, right?
- Right.
- So let's go talk about
what a fraction is.
It might not be the
nearest neighbor standard
that's the issue, it could
be some ways of thinking
that endure and that goes
back to your question
about who are these for?
Well, you can take the ones
that we've got packaged
in the third grade and ask them*8
to seventh and eighth graders,
because the ways of thinking
are enduring, right?
And so the ideas are, yes,
they grow a little bit,
but they endure and they
grew out of these things,
actually grew out of, are
thinking about what could we help
to provide teachers with as
we move into this phase now,
where students are coming with
such uneven opportunities to learn.
And philosophically I'd say,
well, I can't just be
focus on ways of doing.
I have to be focusing some
way on the ways of thinking
and these habits of thinking
that come alongside it.
And so what could we do?
That's where we ended up with this.
So if you are a third grade teacher,
you could probably pull stuff
from the fourth and fifth grade.
If you are a high school teacher,
you can pull things
from any grades, right?
And they'll still be fair game
because there're things to talk about,
ideas that endure that go on and on.
So if you're in high school,
you might dig into the functions,
you might dig into comparison,
you might dig into operations.
I hope you dig into
proportional relationships.
- Yes, so this whole conversation
is making me think about
something that we talk a lot
about at Khan Academy which is,
what Sal used to call Swiss cheese gaps
but now everyone calls
unfinished learning.
Which is the idea that lots of folks
didn't get some of those
foundational concepts
and when they were first
presented and so try to then build
the next level without those concepts,
which is kinda the shaky
foundation and it just keeps going.
So it sounds like these
conversation starters
are starting to think about
almost diagnosing in some ways,
like do you have those-
- Do you have the ways of thinking, right?
The foundational ways
of thinking which are,
when you look at your state standards,
you're going to see them kind of in there,
but you might not see them as explicit
as we're trying to call them out here.
Like these are some core ones
that you wanna keep coming back to.
You wanna keep revisiting
these and keep listening.
And so the kinds of questions
that we're putting out here,
use them however you wanna
use them, use them full class,
use them one on one, use
them in small groups,
use them for turning talks,
the idea is to sit back and listen.
What we would point out
is it's also not intended,
there will be a teachable
moment, it's not during this time
because we wanna set up the
culture in such a way that
this is free, open up, tell
me what you're thinking
and it's not to correct, it's to listen.
And what's interesting about that, right?
Is if you keep asking more questions,
you might realize that your first thoughts
about what people like
to call misconceptions
could be completely wrong.
That you've misconceived
their misconceptions.
(both laughing)
I don't like using the word misconceptions
'cause the students have the conceptions
and this is all about,
what conceptions might they have, right?
Not what don't they have, what
conceptions might they have?
How are they thinking about these things?
And let's build from that,
that connects back very closely
to Sal's house building analogy, right?
- Yeah, right.
- These are these foundational,
it's more like these foundational threads
that wind their way all the way through,
not just on the bottom floor
but you just keep continuing
to strengthen them like
the trunk of a tree, right?
It just keeps getting
stronger and stronger.
- Yeah, absolutely, that
totally makes sense.
How do you think about the
idea of mastery in this world?
We talk a lot about mastery learning here
and thinking it's easy when
you're talking about skills
and having mastery of skills,
but mastery of some of these
things is somewhat different.
Is that even a valid concept?
I don't know.
- Yeah, it's so hard
to say what is mastery.
I mean, we always wanna draw a line
for proficiency somewhere, right?
- Right.
- What it means to have learned something
but in this mindset on
the ways of thinking,
it's like these are things
that continue to grow
and morph and evolve.
And as I think about, well,
how do we ever establish
whether students have mastered this?
I'm not sure that that's even
the right type of question.
But rather to just likely,
it's just to keep on
how is that scheme of
building up in their minds
as they continue to go and
how can I leverage that
to go on to that next place?
- Right and you can think
about how you would expect
some of these answers to
change as you learn new things,
you're changing your
ideas about what these are
as you kind of move up through new skills
and things you're developing, interesting.
So we obviously do a lot with technology
but we also wanna think about
how teachers and technology work together.
And so I'm interested
in your thoughts about,
the interplay between
the two is I think about
what you're talking about,
things technology's never gonna be good
at doing what you're talking
about, that's like the thing
that teachers need to be in classrooms.
So I'm interested in your
thoughts about how teachers
and technology can work
together to build on.
- Yeah, so I'm happy to
hear you see it that way
'cause that's how I see it.
It's that idea that
computers, they're really good
at helping with that way
of doing things, right?
- Right.
- But to sort of put these complex
ways of thinking together,
I mean, that takes some time
and working and developing
and to me I see a very human side to that
that would be very hard to
capture with a computer system.
So each can play a very
important role, right?
So the computers provide
an here to foreseen access
to content in ways that we've
never seen before, right?
And so building that up,
but that next task is,
well, how do we take that
access that we've now shared,
but how do we build in
these kinds of things?
What can we have the computers
help to support us with
when it comes to engaging in
these kinds of conversations
that will be able to help
sort of listen to students
and figure out exactly sort
of what might the next move be
based on ways of thinking,
not necessarily just the ways
of doing as you might see
pointed out in standards
and standards mappings, that kinda thing.
- Yeah, absolutely.
So another piece that we try to encourage
is helping students become
owners of their own learning
and thinking about developing
those metacognitive skills.
Being able to understand what they know
and evaluate and what they understand
and need to learn and how those fit in.
I'm interested in how you think about that
and some of this framework too.
- Yeah, well that might land
in that habits space, right?
Being able to reflect on and
being honest with myself,
am I making sense?
In my own mind can I
justify what I'm saying?
Or am I just spouting things off?
So maybe part of that is that you can
with this type of approach you
really do get the opportunity
for the student to reflect
by not correcting right away,
by continuing to ask questions.
You're providing the student
opportunities to reflect
and then maybe when it's
done and then you sit down
with the student and
then you help them have
some metacognitive reflection on it.
What would you like to work on it?
What questions did you
answer that you felt like
you wanted to take back
or think through again,
or think more about or
learn more about, right?
To help them spot where they need ways
they wanted to strengthen
their ways of thinking.
- Yeah, that makes sense.
I think that idea of
helping of thinking about
your confidence in your answers
is something that we talk about too,
like after students give
answers having them think about,
so how sure of you were with that answer
and what did you know
and didn't you know and
I could see them doing it
with this too, so asking students,
what do you think a fraction is?
And then how confident
are you in that answer
and where that fits in would
be interesting to think about,
yeah, definitely.
So as you think about advising
teachers on next steps,
so they've had this conversation,
what is the next thing they should do
based on the information that they get?
- Well, I think as you're listening,
you're trying to interpret, right?
What are you noticing?
Work on those, what do you wanna notice
with what the student's saying.
Reflect back on it, the things
that we're putting together
around these, we've got some videos
and it's very fun to sit and
watch because you get to,
if you watch it two or
three times sometimes
you'll get even more and more out of it.
So it's, yeah, teachers,
what could you do with these?
(both laughing)
I don't know, did I answer that okay or?
- Yeah, so the idea, it's going to have,
the teachers are gonna have to do
some pretty good interpretation
of what they're hearing
and then think about based on that
what are the understandings
that they need to either fill in
or move forward or what that looks like.
- And it's also self-reflective.
I mean, when we were putting
these, they made all of us
stop and think, we had
to sit there and think,
"Oh, how would we answer this?"
'Cause basically we weren't
putting questions down
to get right or wrong answers.
It's coming up with questions
that uncover thinking
and you don't have to ask
right or wrong questions
to uncover thinking.
- Right, yeah, I think
that's another piece
in math education that we're
coming to better understandings
that math education isn't just
about right and wrong answers
and where things are.
Math does have right and wrong
answers to some things, but.
- I'm not minimizing the need
for right or wrong answers.
But there's a time for that
and there's a time for
listening to thinking.
- Yeah, that totally
makes sense, excellent.
So anything that you're excited about,
I'll close on this question.
Anything you're excited about
in the coming couple of months
that your team work is working on.
- Oh yeah, so one of the
things I'm working on,
I just did a talk on this at
South by Southwest last week
and I called it mathematical rigor mortis,
the quest for a cure.
And it's this idea where when we sit back
and we think about our
field math teachers,
we think about how many ways
does math kill things, right?
Math kills dreams, it kills
joy, it kills progress.
And also it also kills moving policy
in the right directions
and making changes at systemic levels.
This things are so entrenched
in the way that we do things,
but I'm encouraged and I'm encouraged
and I hope that the folks
out there are encouraged
that I think we're moving
in the right direction
to cure mathematical rigor mortis.
And if you ever wanna reach
out and talk to me about it,
I'd love to go into that as well.
But that's something I'm encouraged about
is the sort of spaces and the things
I'm seeing across the
country to help address that.
- And we had a question
from Angel on YouTube,
who's a student and wants
to know how they can stay
motivated when they're doing work.
We hear this question a lot from folks
who are needing to stay
motivated to do their work.
What do you think?
- Oh, so maybe Angel and
I hope this is helpful
but if math is being presented to you
as though it's the
collection of puzzle pieces.
That you're just shaking the box
and you can kinda hear them rattling,
the challenge would be to know that
it does make a big, beautiful picture,
that all of the pieces fit together,
that no piece stands alone.
And that if you find that encouraging
then you can figure out how
these pieces fit together,
what's the story that's being told here.
It's a great one and
there are lots of places
where you could go to help get
some support on that as well.
But don't let the current
situations that you might be in,
or these things that are
happening all around us right now,
don't let them destroy the joy
that mathematics has for you.
That would be my take.
- I like it and putting
together that puzzle
could be a challenge, a
fun challenge to undertake
and to think through, excellent.
- Yeah, but it's there, it's
ready to be put together,
but it gets put together in your own head.
- Fantastic, well thank you
so much for joining us today.
It was a pleasure to talk to you
and I hope some of our folks out there
dive into those conversation starters.
- Well, thank you, this was great.